der reichste Mensch der Welt kauft die
wichtigste globale meinungsbörse seit
tesla-chef Elon Musk Twitter sein eigen
nennt herrscht Aufregung in der
digitalen Blase soll man bleiben oder
gehen fragen sich die Nutzer und schauen
sich nach Alternativen um Donald Trump
darf jetzt auch wieder zwitschern wie
viel Meinungen wird im Netz gemacht
Instagram Facebook WhatsApp bestimmen
das Leben von 3,7 Milliarden Menschen
weltweit was bedeutet das für unsere
Demokratie Twitter Facebook Google wie
mächtig sind Elon Musk und Co unser
Thema in der Phönix Runde
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
herzlich willkommen aus Berlin wie auch
immer sie uns zuschauen entweder live
bei Twitter oder Youtube oder eben am
späteren Abend im Fernsehen sprechen wir
über Macht und Ohnmacht in den sozialen
Medien mit diesen Gästen ich begrüße
missbarkan Bundestagsabgeordnete für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Mitglied im
digitalausschuss und auch noch bei
Twitter aktiv und herzlich willkommen
Prof Bernhard perksen Professor für
Medienwissenschaft an der Universität
Tübingen der Twitter still beobachtet
und interessiert Männer Funk ist bei uns
sie ist Schriftstellerin und Autorin und
sie ist nicht bei Twitter aktiv
zugeschaltet ist uns chanyon er ist
Fachanwalt für IT-Recht und hat mehrfach
gegen Facebook geklagt und jetzt auch
gegen Twitter und ist doch dort noch
aktiv diesmal vermerken wir dass wir
hier aktiv ist weil es doch bei dieser
Sendung auch eine Rolle spielt Herr
Ochsen es gibt jetzt Aufregung darum
dass Elon Musk eben der reichste Mann
der Twitter gekauft hat und viele fragen
sich wie gehen wir damit um wie
beurteilen Sie diese auf und ich finde
die Aufregung völlig berechtigt weil wir
sehen hier im Grunde genommen wie unter
einem Brennglas ein eine Situation die
wir schon seit langem beobachten einige
wenige Superreiche im Falle von Elon
Musk durchaus mit libertärer Ideologie
haben viel zu viel Macht bestimmt viel
zu viel was das Klima unserer
öffentlichen Meinung oder unsere
Meinungsfindung angeht das ist das all
die eine Seite und auf der anderen Seite
und genau das zeigt sich ja jetzt dass
die Userin und Joseph von Twitter
aufstehen und eigentlich um das Klima
auf ihrer ja zum Teil auch fantastischen
Plattform kämpfen also es ist ein großes
Lehrstück über unsere Kommunikations
Zukunft des aktuellen stattfindet wem
gehört eigentlich Öffentlichkeit was
sind
gemeinwohlorientierte Geschäftsmodelle
um ein gutes kommunikationsklima nicht
die sind frei gewiss nicht zu sichern
und wie viel Macht darf ein einzelner
haben in dem Fall ja ein libertärer
Dialoge der so Mischung ist aus
gigantischem kapitalvernichter er zu
verbraucht ja ungeheure Massen von Geld
bringt das Unternehmen innerhalb
kürzester Zeit an den Rand der Insolvenz
aus Internet Troll und politischem
Provokateur der die Republikaner
empfiehlt und nun ganz eindeutig
erkennbar diese Plattform ideologisch
umzubauen gedenkt als ein Instrument der
Ideologieproduktion zu verstehen gedenkt
okay Frau Funk sie haben in einem
Kommentar in der Welt geschrieben sie
finden das elonas ist zum Hass zu
Hassfigur für deutsche Spießer geworden
also sie verteidigen eigentlich was
finden sie gut annehmen ich habe ihn
nicht verteilt ich habe extra in dem
Artikel gesagt dass ich ihn sozusagen
wieder verteidige noch verteufel sondern
dass ich es wichtig finde ihn als
mehrdimensionale Personen zu betrachten
und ihn eben nicht zu verteufeln ich
sehe ihn z.B auch nicht als in Ideologen
und ich glaube dass es wichtig ist wenn
wir
zurückholt jemand der das
informationsproduzenten zurückholt
jemand der Leute zurückholt die die
Pandemie leugnen und der das als ein
solches Projekt im Dienste der
Meinungsfreiheit betreibt und der sich
selbst auch so versteht und so
positioniert der ist hat ein
ideologisches Projekt Frau Funk erst
einmal ausführen ja vielleicht darf ich
vorher noch mal ein bisschen was sagen
also ich glaube dass es dass die große
Frage ist ja wer darf was sagen das
diese Frage die müssen wir uns ja schon
lange stellen ja also wer entscheidet
wann die Grenzen das Sagbaren erreicht
sind und das Problem ist sozusagen immer
wer entscheidet was sagt Bar und was
nicht sagt weil ist und
ich aus meiner Position heraus ist das
äh Elon Musk sehr klar dass wir uns an
so einem Scheideweg befinden wie wie wie
wie schaffen wir Freiheit wir schaffen
ja auch Meinungsfreiheit wenn bestimmte
Leute eben entscheiden dass das nicht
mehr gesagt werden kann und ich
natürlich auch antisemitisches Leute
nicht gesagt werden nun müsste man
darüber diskutieren ob kann ihr West
jetzt ausschließlich Antisemit ist auch
über den habe ich geschrieben und als
Jüdin kann ich vielleicht dazu auch was
sagen ob der ob ich den als Antisemiten
verstehe ja aber wichtig ist zugelassen
wurde ist ein Account erst gesperrt
genau so ein sehr bekannter bekannter
Rapper und
und ich glaube dass wir uns generell
natürlich darüber Gedanken machen müssen
was es sag mal was es nicht sagbar und
wer entscheidet was sagt bei und was ich
was nicht sagbar ist bevor Sie jetzt nur
zu zweit als ich bekämpfen müssen Frau
Khan sie sind ja noch bei bei Twitter
sind digital Expertin für die Grünen im
Bundestag also wie gefährlich finden Sie
es oder das Ellen Maske jetzt Twitter
übernommen hat und bestimmte Accounts
dann auch wieder freigeschaltet hat ich
finde es auf jeden Fall problematisch
ich sehe das auch so wie Herr parksen da
gibt's ja auch einige Zahlen und
Statistiken dazu wie das Umfeld die
Öffentlichkeit reagiert hat auf dem Kauf
und man hat da zahlenstatistiken die
zeigen es gibt einen Ansturm an Rechten
Menschen die sich wieder willkommen
fühlen auf der Plattform das ist ein
Problem und grundsätzlich glaube ich
zeigt das aber an einem ganz konkreten
Fallbeispiel was wir grundsätzlich
brauchen bei Plattformen nämlich mehr
Reglementierung und eine klare Ansage
durch den Staat oder durch Europa an der
Stelle DSL ist dann Schlagwort also das
digitale dienstegesetz es kann nicht
sein das Plattform für sich entscheiden
was in Ordnung ist und was nicht das ist
ja auch nicht so es ist ja es gibt ja
Gesetze dagegen genau das stimmt ganz
oft wird gesagt das Internetplattform
sind in rechts freier Raum das ist nicht
so wir haben die Gesetze wir haben
Probleme mit einer rechts Durchsetzung
Herr Juden das ist der gute Überleitung
zu ihnen als Anwalt sie haben 2016 gegen
Facebook geklagt und jetzt sind sie in
einem Verfahren gegen Twitter vielleicht
erklären Sie uns noch mal ein bisschen
was sie da genau warum sie klagen
ja sehr gerne also es geht ja nicht um
die Frage wer etwas sagen darf sondern
was man sagen darf und dafür gibt es
eigentlich klare Regeln nämlich das
Gesetz und wir sehen jetzt gerade den
Showdown Elon Musk hat da eine andere
Auffassung seine eigenen Regeln und wir
müssen uns jetzt einmal nicht
entscheiden wollen wir unsere Diskurse
führen nach den Regeln von Elon Musk
oder nach den Werten unseres
Grundgesetzes zum Beispiel den Werten
der Menschen würde und der
Meinungsfreiheit und die daraus
entstehenden Gesetzen wir haben einen
Prozess begonnen der war schon vor der
Übernahme durch Elon Musk bei
gerichtsanhängig es geht dort in dem
einzelnen Fall um einen
antisemitismusbeauftragten
Baden-Württemberg Herr Blume der immer
wieder angefeindet wird und zwar auch
mit rechtswidrigen Inhalten und Facebook
nein nicht facebook twitter hat sich
geweigert diese Sachen auch nur näher zu
betrachten zu prüfen oder gar zu
entfernen manchmal wurde etwas entfernt
das war dann eher irratisch und zufällig
wurde dann aber wieder online gestellt
und es geht uns in dem Verfahren darum
klarzustellen dass ich Twitter an
deutsches und europäisches Recht halten
muss und auch ein bisschen in die
Spielregeln zu konkretisieren was nach
rechtswidrigen Inhalten damit passieren
muss denn Elon Musk möchte am liebsten
alles über Algorithmen über Computer
lösen dass man schaut ist da ein Stich
ein Schimpfwort drin und nur solche
Sachen entfernen was ja am günstigsten
ist und Meinungsfreiheit ist nicht so
billig zu kriegen
[Musik]
nämlich gerne unterstreichen ich finde
auch das ist ein Problem also diese
Vorstellung davon gesellschaftliche
Probleme mit technischen Lösungen in
irgendeiner Form bewältigen zu wollen
greift zu kurz das haben wir ein ganz
ganz vielen Stellen im digitalen Raum
und da auch also zu glauben man kann mit
Algorithmen mit einem Problem gerecht
werden dass Menschen meinen im Internet
andere Menschen bedrohen und beleidigen
zu können das funktioniert so nicht da
braucht man wirkliche echte Menschen die
sich konkrete Fälle anschauen aber was
was ändert sich dadurch dass Elon Musk
jetzt Twitter gehört was ist denn die
Menschen können ja wer möchte und kann
ja sich äußern dort
muss man ja sagen
völlig rechtsfrei was dort veranstaltet
wurde wie Verleumdungskampagnen
stattgefunden haben was was dort Leute
über andere Menschen erzählen und so das
ist ja nicht so dass jetzt Elon kommt
und aus diesem Ort jetzt plötzlichen
ganzen schreckensort Macht der vorher
kein schreckensort war das war ja schon
sozusagen das Problem existiert ja schon
schon lange mit Twitter
bringen wir können ja eindeutig zeigen
und das Beobachten ja auch viele
Userinnen und User im Moment die um ihre
Plattform Kämpfen auf eine durchaus
berührende Weise dass sich das
kommunikationsklima gerade jetzt radikal
verändert also es gibt Indizien dass der
die Leugnung des Menschen gemacht und
Klimawandels zunehmend dass die das
Information zu Pandemie zunehmend Alter
dafür gibt es deutlicher Hinweise wir
haben auch gerade in den letzten Jahren
gesehen übrigens belegt durch Studien
wie ungeheuer gefährlich Desinformation
für westliche Gesellschaften ist wir
haben in Zeiten der Pandemie ganz
konkret erleben können dass
Desinformation in einem sehr konkreten
und direkten Sinne tödlich sind tödlich
ist wir haben sehr konkret und direkt
erlebt dass Desinformation spaltet
Populisten Auftrieb gibt Gesellschaften
unter minimiert und unterspült und
letzter Satz letzte Bemerkung wir haben
auch erlebt dass Desinformation uns bei
der Krisenbewältigung blockiert wir
haben gewaltige Krisen die Klimakrise
die Pandemie andere die auf diese
Gesellschaft zu rollen und die nicht so
nötig machen wie globale Kooperation
wirkliches miteinander transnationale
Kooperation und genau das wird Durchgang
daraus wird unterspült durch eine neue
Macht von Desinformationen und mask
steht für eine Öffnung und weiter um das
kommunikativen Raumes quer zu den
Gesetzen die in diesem Land gelten er
lässt Meinungen zu als Meinungen die
schlicht und einfach Schmierung sind und
deshalb ist es hier eine Veränderung die
Beispiel zu diskutieren ist
also bitte wissen Sie ich glaube wir
sollten uns mal wieder für gegenwärtigen
das ist ja ein Unterschied gibt zwischen
der Meinungsfreiheit wie wir es in
Deutschland haben und der freedom of
speech in Amerika denn der Schutzbereich
von Freedom speech ist viel viel weiter
wir haben uns in Deutschland damals
dagegen entschieden Tatsachen
Behauptungen unter den Schutz des
Grundgesetzes zu stellen sondern wir
haben gesagt wir schützen nur Meinungen
Meinungsfreiheit und hier prallen eben
zwei verfassungssysteme aufeinander
lieber was ist davon überzeugt dass jede
Tatsache erst einmal behauptet werden
darf und da haben wir einfach
unterschiedliche Systeme und wir sind in
letzter Zeit nicht gut darin gewesen
unser System zu verteidigen wir haben
immer geglaubt wir könnten mit kleinen
runden und freundlichen runden Tischen
Konsens mit Facebook und Google und
Twitter finden und wir sehen doch hier
bei Elon Musk ganz klar das muss
durchgesetzt werden rechtsfreier Raum
ich muss dann immer lachen weil faktisch
haben wir einen rechtsverfolgungsfreien
Raum wir sehen einfach das Twitter damit
durchkommt und das Bundesamt Justiz
nicht ein einziges Bußgeld gegen eine
einzige Plattform in den letzten Jahren
verhängt hat und das ist wirklich sehr
bedauerlich was denken Sie woran das
liegt weil die Gesetze sind ja da es
gibt dieses
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes
im Internet
ich habe 14 Stunden vor mit dem
Prozessbeginn in Frankfurt erfahren
durch eine nächtlichen Schriftsätze
Gegenseite das Twitter die Erlaubnis hat
sich über das Netzwerk
durchsetzungsgesetz hinwegzusetzen dass
also eine stillhaltevereinbarung
getroffen worden ist dass kein
gegenvorstellungsverfahren durchgeführt
werden muss also da hat man halt eine
Absprache getroffen und gesagt gut
dieses Gesetz setzen wir auf Eis denn
bis das gerichtliche entschieden ist ob
das wirksam ist oder nicht dann ist ja
sowieso der dieses a da ich glaube das
ist
ja kein Geheimnis gesagt hat wie machen
das lieber auf europäischer Ebene das
ist aber unabhängig von dem Besitz von
allen Maske das war auch vorher schon
ein Problem
das war schon vorher das Problem
ist wie wichtig ist Twitter eigentlich
Frau kann wenn man sagt das ist ja nur
ein kleinerer Teil der Bevölkerung ist
es einfach viel zu ja überschätzen wir
das auch und ist es vor allen Dingen
interessant weil er eine Maske auch als
Tesla Chefin interessante Figur ist und
natürlich auch einfach auch noch andere
ja also sehr mächtig
es ist deshalb auch so wichtig jetzt
oder sagen ist es eigentlich überschätzt
ich glaube Twitter war schon immer
wichtig und relevant ist es nicht die
allergrößte Plattform gewesen aber sie
war universell universell darin dass ein
denk austauschen Informationsaustausch
auf dieser Plattform anders
stattgefunden hat als auf anderen und
zuerst Beurteilung zum Austausch mit
ExpertInnen Experten mit JournalistInnen
Journalisten und auch mit der Politik
das hat woanders nicht so funktioniert
und deshalb ist es eine ganz ganz
besondere Plattform die auch schon
vorher eine besondere Relevanz hatte wir
benutzen Sie es so sagen sie da ist
Twitter für mich echt wichtig deshalb
bin ich dann also mich erreichen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger natürlich
irgendwie per Mail aber ganz oft
schreiben Sie mir auch eine
Twitter-Nachricht also öfter als bei
Instagram wo habe ich dann als Bürger
oder als BürgerInnen die Möglichkeit
direkt mit einer PolitikerInnen
Austausch zu treten wenn ich mich
austauschen möchte mit Expertin und
Experten zu einem ganz spezifischen
digitalpolitischen oder in politischen
Thema dann kann ich das machen ich höre
und diese ganz schnell Position zu
aktueller Tagespolitik das ist
einzigartig und deshalb auch ganz ganz
wichtig und deshalb macht es auch einen
Unterschied ob Twitter vorher schon in
toxischer Raum war und das das kann man
vielleicht auch so sehen bestimmt da
gibt es auch genug Studien aber es wird
eben schlimmer und aber Frau von sie
haben selber auch gesagt ich mache da
nicht mit ich bin bei Instagram und
nicht bei Twitter warum also ich habe
ich war nie wirklich aktiv bei Twitter
ich hatte einen Account und dann habe
ich den aber wirklich schon vor zwei
Jahren zweieinhalb ich weiß es ehrlich
gar nicht ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau
oder sogar schon drei Jahre ist das hier
den Account gelöscht weil die
Kommunikation die dort stattgefunden hat
ich als wirklich also ich kann das nicht
mal als Kommunikation bezeichnen ich
halte das wirklich von total furchtbaren
Ort ähm ich finde aber auch das ist in
Ordnung ist wenn Menschen an diesem Ort
unbedingt sein möchten und kommunizieren
wollen das ist nicht meine Form zu
kommunizieren und ich habe Twitter
verlassen und und bin eben selbst
trotzdem auch Opfer von
Verleumdungskampagnen auf Twitter
geworden ohne dass ich dort war und habe
natürlich mitbekommen was das bedeutet
wenn dort irgendwelche Tatsachen
behauptet wäre hatten und so ja also ich
glaube auch nicht also ich halte auch
Twitter wirklich nicht für wichtig ich
glaube das Twitter in den letzten Jahren
vor allem von den Medien viel zu viel zu
sozusagen aufgebauscht wurde und auch zu
wichtig gemacht wurde wir haben es dort
mit einem unglaublich kleinen Teil der
Gesellschaft zu tun ja wir haben also
wirklich nur 8 Millionen Twitter konnten
also was sind 8 Millionen Twitter
konnten in Deutschland davon sind ja
wirklich wahrscheinlich die Hälfte
überhaupt richtig aktiv das heißt da
diskutieren irgendwie 4 Millionen
Menschen ähm und was sind also was was
sind 4 Millionen Menschen die
diskutieren in einem in einer
Gesellschaft in der 30 Millionen
existieren also und da sind ganz
bestimmt auch eine es gibt ganz
bestimmte ganz bestimmte politische
Agenten die auf Twitter durchgedrückt
werden und es gibt sozusagen bubbles die
kreiert werden die sich gegenseitig
unterstützen und auch dabei helfen zum
Beispiel dann eben
irgendwelche
empörungsaufregungen zu kreieren und so
das hat ja auch ganz viel das ist ja
eine ganz spezielle Dynamik die auch bei
Twitter die bei Twitter sozusagen ja
auch ausgelöst wird
wie wichtig würden Sie sagen wie wichtig
ist Twitter für die Meinungsbildung in
unserer Gesellschaft wir müssen immer
auf Deutschland ist also aus meiner
Sicht ist Twitter trotz dieser ja
relativ kleinen Nutzerzahlen
außerordentlich wichtig sie können sagen
es ist so eine Art Nachrichtenkanal für
jedermann es ist eine Möglichkeit
Menschen sehr direkt zu erreichen sie
haben es gerade geschildert es ist auch
und das sage ich jetzt als
Wissenschaftler ein wunderbares Recher
Tool also ich tauche eigentlich jeden
einzelnen Tag ein in Erkenntnis und
Forschungsgemeinschaften bekommen sofort
Materialien entlegenste Art Aufsätze
zugespielt bekomme auch die Möglichkeit
es ist mir in der Pandemie so
eindrücklich vor Augen geführt worden
gewissermaßen die Welt durch die Brille
eines Virologen einer virologin und zu
betrachten und zu sehen was wird da im
Moment tatsächlich in diesem in diesem
Moment der Unruhe diskutiert also ich
halte das Medium für sehr sehr wichtig
wir erleben es auch jetzt im laufenden
Ukraine Krieg wie militärexpertin und
Experten Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
unterstützen das hat auch was sehr
berühren das also ich würde die
Plattform auch nicht absolut absolut das
schafft eine ganz andere Nähe und zum
Teil eben auch Empathie also ich würde
eigentlich sagen dass auf Twitter trotz
dieser vielen toxischen
kommunikationsverhältnisse die wir
beobachten ist eben auch diese
Gemeinschaften gibt die wirklich einen
Erkenntnisprozess miteinander erleben
und treiben und auch durchaus
respektvoll oder sich fördernd
miteinander umgehen das ist das
erstaunliche eben und deswegen ist es
Ringen so groß und ist auch die
Enttäuschung so groß viele Menschen
erleben das jetzt also eine kalte
Enteignung jetzt wird sozusagen ein
neues Klima das so vorher noch nicht da
war erst mal gesetzt aber dann könnte
man ja sagen es ist ja jeder Freitag
damit zu machen denn man könnte die
könnten doch den was denn entgegensetzen
also es wird ja niemandem verboten sich
dort zu äußern Politik war ja vorher
eine andere Jack Johnson hat sehr viel
genauer verstanden wie gefährlich das
Information ist hat sehr viel striktere
moderationspolitik Betrieben Elon
Muskeln Twitter Hauptquartier eingezogen
kurios Gewalt sie können es auf Twitter
sehen hat er einen Waschbecken vor sich
hier getragen und danach hat er die
Hälfte der Belegschaft gefeuert
das ist das was passiert ist und unter
anderem auch
das ist eine Stil das hat mit Twitter
überhaupt
nicht so tun wenn man sich mit Mast
beschäft
igt seit Jahren gesprochen wird das hat
ja schon bei Tesla so gemacht das macht
er in seinem in seinem SpaceX
mask hat eine ein sehr speziellen
Führungsstil den kann man kritisieren
das kann man schwierig finden aber das
ist jetzt nicht da ist da passiert jetzt
nicht etwas was anders ist als es vorher
war und als anders als mask in sein
Unternehmen die er geführt hat agiert
hat er feuert er lässt Leute rund um die
Uhr arbeiten das ist sozusagen das ist
sein Style und wie gesagt das kann man
schwierig finden aber das ist er er
bringt sozusagen sein Führungsstil den
er bei Tesla so lebt und den dabei
SpaceX so lebt den bringt er jetzt eben
zu zu Twitter und ich will mal eine
Sache noch mal sagen
hätte ja nicht verkaufen müssen an Musk
niemand hat dorthin gezwungen
42 Billionen Euro zu verdienen
ja
die Frage ist es ein Unterschied wenn es
um eine Autofabrik gibt oder eben um
einen um eine Plattform die für unsere
Demokratie wichtig ist das würde ich
ganz gerne sie auch noch mal fragen wie
wenn man was macht was für ein
Unterschied ist das dass eben Twitter
jetzt allen was gehört und nicht
irgendeiner demokratisch gewählten
Institutionen wäre das überhaupt geht es
überhaupt eine Alternative Frau kann
also es ist natürlich ein Unterschied
was machen Unterschied ob ich ein
Unternehmen schlecht führe oder ob ich
eine soziale Plattform vielleicht führe
und da vielleicht dafür Sorge mit dem
Argument hat mit dem Argument der
Meinungsfreiheit
ein Haufen Mitarbeiter kündige also was
bedeutet das für die IT-Sicherheit der
Plattform das bedeutet meine Daten wenn
ich nicht sicherstellen kann dass er
nicht übermorgen liegt ist und meine
persönliche Kommunikation oder andere
persönliche Daten plötzlich in der Welt
sind also das befürchten sie konkret das
ist jetzt und das Problem ist mit der
Cyber Sicherheit weil es eben viel mehr
viel weniger Mitarbeiter jetzt gibt
genau also er hat er hat relativ große
Bereiche also kündigt Mitarbeiter und
der IT-Bereich ist auf jeden Fall einer
also die Sicherheit ist so nicht mehr
gewährleistet und wenn ich aber
argumentiere mit Meinungsfreiheit und
dann aber nicht verstehe das Content
Moderation auch dem Bereich sind ganz
viele Leute gekündigt gekündigt worden
in relevanter Faktor ist um die
Meinungsfreiheit überhaupt erst zu
institutionalisieren dann habe ich ein
Problem nicht verstanden wollen wir
nicht mehr darüber sprechen dass er
einfach ganz normal rechtmäßig sich
dieses Unternehmen erkauft hat ne er hat
das ja rechtmäßig einfach gekauft er hat
das ja nicht dass er keine Diktatur er
hat das ja nicht eingenommen oder so
darüber sprechen dass diejenigen die den
Twitter gehört hat die haben alle
Twitter User und alle Mitarbeiter in
genau diese Situation gebracht in der
wir jetzt sind kein Elon Musk das stimmt
aber man kann trotzdem nicht machen was
er möchte er hat sich an Recht und
Gesetz zu halten
natürlich würde ich ihre Meinung gern
auch noch mal zuhören was das für ein
Unterschied ist wenn er da Twitter
eigentlich gar keine Rolle wem Twitter
gehört und es steht uns auch nicht zu zu
entscheiden wer das kaufen darf oder
nicht darf denn jedes Unternehmen muss
ja in Rechnung Gesetz halten das ist
jetzt irgendwie eine Phrase dir schon
mehrmals gefallen ist und das ist
eigentlich offenkundig aber wenn wir ein
Unternehmer ein Management haben was
nicht von sich aus intrinsisch motiviert
ist sich an Werte oder Gesetze zu halten
dann muss man halt als Aufsichtsbehörde
auch mal aufwachen und ein bisschen mehr
auf die Finger schauen und nicht das
alleine in der amerikanischen
Aufsichtsbehörden überlassen also hier
ist jetzt wirklich die Bundesregierung
gefordert solange das Netz
durchsetzungsgesetz noch bis 20 24 gilt
regulieren hier einzugreifen und dann
überhaupt keine Entfaltung und
Aktivitäten machen Sie sich mal konkret
was fordern Sie ganz konkret jetzt von
der Bundesregierung von
Bundesjustizministerin
was fordern Sie da und was welche
Möglichkeiten gibt es da überhaupt
also das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist
ja dafür eingeführt worden um
durchzusetzen und da gibt es die
Möglichkeit mit Bußgeldern von bis zu 50
Millionen Euro gegen Unternehmen
vorzugehen die zum Beispiel systematisch
die moderationspflichten Verletzen man
war da sehr vorsichtig hat gesagt nicht
wegen einem einzigen Fehler sondern wenn
man sieht da gibt es eine Systematik die
sehen wir wir sehen ganz genau das
überall dort wo falsch Nachrichten oder
Personen verbreitet werden Verleumdung
über Nachrede das Twitter dort nicht
einmal den Sachverhalt aufklärt im
Gegensatz zu Google übrigens sieht das
besser machen auch sogar Facebook
mittlerweile man könnte sofort reingehen
und dort ein Bußgeld verhängen man
könnte natürlich Ermittlungen anstellen
aber es wird anscheinend nicht einmal
mehr angehört also wir sehen jedenfalls
nicht das Twitter sich unter Druck
gesetzt wird im Gegenteil man schließt
stillhalte Abkommen also man hat das
Instrumentarium nur nutzt es nur nicht
aus anscheinend wartet man auf die
Europäische Kommission aber das dauert
noch anderthalb Jahre genau weil das
Netz durchsetzen würde dann ersetzt
durch das europäische durch den Digital
serviceakt der aber erst 20 24 glaube
ich letztendlich in Kraft tritt richtig
richtig wir könnten jetzt noch wir
müssen jetzt noch was wir können ja
nicht einfach warten bis die Kommission
sich da in Position gebracht hat wir
haben das Gesetz sie haben es auch am
Anfang ernst genommen aber die letzten
zwei Jahre haben die ganzen
Plattformbetreiber gesehen oh das meinen
die gar nicht so ernst das war hier eher
ein symbolischer Art es gibt kein
einziges Bußgeld nicht ein einziger Euro
jedenfalls für die systematische
Verletzung der moderationspflichten und
da müssen wir ansetzen weil Twitter man
kann den Fernbleiben es mögen auch nur 8
Millionen Account sein aber es prägt die
Art wie wir unsere Meinungen bilden und
das kriegt dann das was auf der Straße
stattfindet also ich halte es für
hochgradig gefährlich und wichtig dass
diese Plattform sich dann Recht und
Gesetz hält was wir wäre dann aber eine
Alternative wenn man sagt man das
gefällt mir dann doch nicht wie das da
passiert es gibt ja auch genug Leute die
jetzt sagen ich verlasse Twitter was
bedeutet das ist gibt also Mastodon ist
ein eine Plattform die anders
funktioniert Frau kann ist das ein Punkt
wo sie sagen okay dann gehe ich eben
dahin ich bin auch bei Master dann
tatsächlich ich bin auf beiden Plattform
aktiv und sie haben ihre Vor- und
Nachteile jeweils
machst du dann ist datensparsamer es
gibt kein Algorithmus der mich irgendwie
vor der Posts vorsortiert in Deutschland
gegründet es ist ein es ist auf Open
Source Basis ich kann
ich will nicht zu technisch werden aber
ich kann dafür sorgen dass bestimmte
Blasen einfach nicht mich erreichen oder
ich sie nicht erreiche wenn man einzelne
Instanzen hat es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Alternative es ist aber nicht das
Gleiche also wenn man erwartet ein
Twitter ein klein zu bekommen dann ist
das vielleicht das dass man kriegt aber
auch nicht mehr als das
wie sehen sie ist das jetzt einige dann
sagen wir gucken mal ob wir eine andere
Möglichkeit haben gibt es überhaupt eine
andere Möglichkeit die ist eine
Alternative zu Twitter ja es gibt
natürlich Alternativen sie haben es
gerade erwähnt das wird ausprobiert ich
persönlich bin nicht sicher ob machst du
dort wirklich funktioniert dann sie
sehen also jemand der ein paar Millionen
verloren hat auf Twitter zieht dann um
zu Mastodon hat vielleicht jetzt wie ein
Böhmermann 66000 Follower immer im
Moment wir wissen aus den entsprechenden
Befragung 80 mit der Deutschen wissen
gar nicht was machst du denn ist das
Problem von hate speech ist nicht gelöst
dass sie haben diese 4000 dezentralen
Server bei Mastodon aber in dem Moment
und das ist ein interessanter Befund in
dem eine Plattform eine gewisse Größe
erreicht kommt eben auch das Problem von
Hass Hetze Diffamierung aber ein
Gesichtspunkt will ich doch noch
einbringen ich war in den letzten beiden
Jahren intensiv im Silicon Valley
unterwegs und habe so die Uhr und
Frühgeschichte der ersten sozialen
Netzwerke studiert und da sehen sie im
Grunde genommen das Erfolgsgeheimnis für
ein gutes kommunikationsklima und das
heißt intensive Moderation eine relative
klar Kleinheit
eigentlich Verzicht auf Data Mining also
ein Grundproblem ist auch das machen die
permanente Ausbeutung der Userinnen und
User zu kommerziellen Zwecken
und
diese diese Kombination von Abo Modellen
intensiver Moderation relativer
Kleinheit die ist durchaus ein
Modell über das sie sich noch mal ganz
neu nachdenken zuletzt das Gute an dem
an der jetzigen
an der jetzigen twitter-krise ist ja das
noch einmal Gesellschaft vor Augen
geführt bekommt was ist möglich und was
läuft schief in der ganz neuen
Direktheit in gewissem Sinne ist die
Figur von Maske auch das hat so
interessant weil sie in ihrer Rohheit in
ihrer Gewalt in ihrer ganzen macht
in einer Person zeigt was schiefläuft
aber die Lösung kann deshalb glaube ich
auch nicht sein zu sagen wir finden eine
andere Plattform wo wir uns vielleicht
glücklicher zu Hause fühlen sondern es
ist ein strukturelles Problem und es
braucht deshalb auch strukturelle
Lösungen wenn man es will gesetzlich und
die Gesetze sind ja da genau da da
wollte ich mir auch ganz kurz ein
ergänzen also das Netzwerk
durchsetzungsgesetz hat ja in einzelnen
Punkten der konkrete Paragraph ist 3 ähm
verfassungsrechtliche Probleme und
Schranken vorgesetzt bekommen also dass
man da nicht weitermachen kann ist klar
es gilt auch trotzdem aber der Rest also
es ist ja nicht so als wäre das Ganze
netz.de aus dem Fenster geworfen sondern
die Paragraphen wo man gerichtlich
gesagt bekommen hat da sind jetzt
unterschiedliche Plattformen gerade
unterwegs und dagegen zu klagen und so
lange greifen oder werden die eben auch
nicht durchgesetzt und da gibt's dieses
stillhalte Abkommen an der Stelle ist
aber auch nicht unüblich sondern einfach
ein Regel riesiges Verfahren aber wir
sind ja schon länger unterwegs in diesen
sozialen Medien und wir merken dieses
Hass hätte die Art wie da kommuniziert
wird ist ja anders als wenn wir auf dem
öffentlichen Marktplatz sind das wissen
wir ja alle vor wenn sie nicht warum ich
glaube was wichtig ist wir reden auch
viel über Falschinformationen also
Falschinformationen gibt es schon so
lange wie es den Menschen gibt und
falsche Informationen haben auch die
letzten Jahrhunderte wirklich
Informationskampagnen gesteuert
isch ja es gab auch information
keine netzwerkwerke ja also Hexen sind
wegen falsch Informationen schon
verbrannt worden Juden sind ermordet
worden wegen Falschinformation also dass
Menschen ähm Behauptungen Ideen
Fantasien in die Welt setzen und durch
durch Gruppen Gruppenbildung diese Ideen
zu Wahrheiten stilisieren und
aufbauschen und damit
gesellschaftliche Veränderungen und auch
schreckliche Ereignisse auslösen das
haben wir also vielleicht wäre es
wichtiger nicht die ganze Zeit über
diese Symptome zu sprechen wie einen
Netzwerk wo 8 Millionen Menschen sind
sondern sich eigentlich zu fragen was
braucht der Mensch ja der Mensch
sozusagen in seiner Existenz in mit
seinen Eigenschaften was muss bei uns am
meisten passieren dass wir zum Beispiel
lernen falsch Informationen
zu erkennen es brauchte eine es braucht
seine Bildung weil das ist ja sozusagen
nur ein ist jetzt ja nur mit einem mit
diesen Netzwerken zu tun die die
spiegeln ja nur unser Mensch sein wieder
da passiert ja nichts was nicht nicht in
unserem sozusagen in unserer Existenz
sowieso schlimmer sagen das Schaufenster
ich muss sagen mir ist lieber zu lesen
was plötzlich irgendwie
einen Christian aus aus Hannover 53 über
über den und denkt als wenn also das
Wissen darum wie Menschen über andere
Menschen reden das wissen auch darum wie
Menschen über Menschengruppen sprechen
das ist das ist ein wichtiges Wissen das
hatten wir ja lange Zeit so gar nicht
weil es ein weil weil dadurch schlimmer
wird es dadurch eben befeuert ich das
ist die das ist eine Frage ob es
befeuert wird aber sie gehen ja auch
nicht weg die Netzwerke werden nicht
weggehen es wird ein neues Netzwerk
geben wenn man ein bisschen länger auf
der Welt ist wir haben alle mal
angefangen mit MySpace jetzt sind wir
irgendwann bei Twitter es wird auch ein
neues Netzwerk geben auch es wird auch
etwas geben was nach Twitter kommt ein
soziales Netzwerk nach Twitter ja und
wir müssen uns aber viel mehr damit
beschäftigen wie können wir Kinder und
Jugendliche
besser bilden in Bezug auf
Falschinformationen auf das was im
Internet passiert
vielleicht wollen wir doch mal darüber
sprechen was die Möglichkeiten sind denn
das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist ja
nicht das einzige was wir an
Möglichkeiten haben vor 100 Jahren fing
der Straßenverkehr an und da braucht man
am Anfang auch keine Regeln und
Netzwerke sind jetzt da und die werden
auch bleiben und wir müssen vielleicht
auch mal einsehen dass wir vielleicht
ein paar mehr Regeln brauchen zwar nicht
nur strafrechtliche Regelungen damit das
Problem beim netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz
dass wir nur bei strafbaren Inhalten
anfangen obwohl es viel viel mehr Sachen
gibt die zum Beispiel niederschwelliger
auf der Ebene von Bußgeldern auch
geahndet werden könnten ich glaube wir
brauchen eine Diskussion dass wir die
Art wie wir miteinander kommunizieren
auch mit Regeln versehen Regeln sind
zwar nicht sexy das macht keinen Spaß
und viele würden sagen lass uns lieber
die Freiheit und den die Vernunft des
Menschen darüber entscheiden wie wir
miteinander reden
dort wo Menschen auch durch ja Geräte
geraten brauchen wir bessere Regeln und
zwar auch kleinere Regeln also eine Art
Ampeln wie im Straßenverkehr
genau okay wie könnte das aussehen haben
Sie eine Idee
ja also wir haben das Problem dass wir
kaum Ordnungswidrigkeiten Tatbestände
also bräuchten eigentlich ein
Bußgeldkatalog für die Sachen die noch
nicht strafbar sind oder wo Strafbarkeit
vielleicht noch einen weiteren Kriterien
hängt wie zum Beispiel die Verbreitung
von solchen falschnachrichten mit den
Menschen gefährdet werden ganz konkret
in sozialen Netzwerken wird in letzter
Zeit immer wieder empfohlen kleinen
Kindern Chlordioxid Tropfen zu geben so
viel bis sie brechen um im Schäden oder
impfwirkungen auszuleiten das ist
totaler Unsinn und wirklich gefährlich
aber es ist nicht verboten so etwas da
verbreitet werden und ich glaube wir
sollten bei solchen Kommunikationsform
tatsächlich überlegen ob sowas nicht
besser mit einem Bußgeld geahndet werden
kann vielleicht ein anderes Beispiel
ist aber dann schwierig wir wollen
Meinungsfreiheit haben das ist ja gerade
vielleicht noch absolut eine aber
meinungsfrei wie vor schon gesagt
schützt ja Meinungen okay
Bemerkung dazu das rechtes sicher ein
ganz wichtiges Instrument aber es ist
vielleicht das letzte Instrument und
vorher gibt es noch sehr viel im Diskurs
in Aushandlungsprozessen und auch in dem
Feld der Bildung und der Erziehung also
für mich ist Medienbildung eigentlich so
etwas wie angewandter demokratieschutz
und wir sehen wir haben eine laufende
Medienrevolution vielleicht vergleichbar
mit der Erfindung der Schrift oder das
Buchdrucks mit beweglichen Lettern und
wir sehen wie ungeheuer lebtarisch
schwerfällig und langsam das Schulsystem
reagiert es macht mir große Hoffnung
dass zunehmend in Deutschland so eine
Art Graswurzelrevolution der
Medienbildung entsteht nämlich aus dem
Journalismus kommt das Journalistinnen
und Journalisten die nichts anderes tun
als Fakt und Fiktion zu unterscheiden
und sich zu überlegen was ist
veröffentlichungsreife überhaupt
vertrauenswürdige Informationen des die
in die Schulen gehen und Schulen
besuchen und da Workshops geben das sind
sehr sehr wichtige aus meiner Sicht
Hilfen Leitplanken denn ich sehe es
nicht ganz so wie sie soziale Netzwerke
sind und wir haben die entsprechenden
Studien die zeigen sind wirken in
ungeheuriger Weise verstärkend ich will
ihn mal ein konkretes Beispiel nennen
von Facebook negativ verstärkt und
manchmal auch positiv verstärkt im Sinne
der politischen Partizipation also
Kollegen hier aus Berlin von Max
Bankinstitut haben gerade eine
Metastudie veröffentlicht haben mal
knapp 500 Studien durchgeguckt und sehen
ganz genau welche Infekte gibt es und
was lässt sich belegen und was nicht
aber ich nehme immer ein ganz konkretes
Beispiel von Facebook 2017 Donald Trump
wird
vereidigt hat sich mit Facebook
nachweislich an die Macht gepöbelt 150
Millionen Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner
haben negativ Post vom Kreml finanziert
gesehen Hillary Clinton ist kriminell in
diesem Jahr verdient Facebook 16
Milliarden gewinnen vor Steuern in
diesem Jahr wird auf Facebook die erste
Kuh an und Gruppe gegründet in diesem
Jahr werden wird auf Facebook zum zu
Ermordung der
aufgerufen in Myanmar dieser
muslimischen Minderheit und man findet
leider keine Zeit um diese hasspostings
zu beseitigen man hat insgesamt drei
Mitarbeiter die irgendwo in Dublin
sitzen von denen man nicht weiß ob sie
überhaupt sprachmächtig und landeskundig
sind um diese hassprotx Postings zu
definieren und macht keinen Mitarbeiter
vor Ort und gleichzeitig geht
facebook-Chef Mark Zuckerberg nach vorne
und hält eine Rede wie großartig ein
Kilometer lang esse auf Facebook
publiziert wie großartig uns Facebook
alle verbindet das ist die Situation
also massives Geld für einzelne
Unternehmen gleichzeitig
Ignoranz von Hass aufrufen die zu
unmittelbar die unmittelbar und
nachweislich zu Gewalt führen und zu
Spalte und ganze Gesellschaft auf der
anderen Seite ist es natürlich auch
genial so ein Instrument wie Facebook zu
erfinden und es sind ja ist ja die Frage
wir nutzen ist ja alles der Erfolg also
die Menge an Menschen die darf auch mit
Whatsapp Instagram unterwegs sind zeigt
ja auch dass es ein großes Bedürfnis
danach gibt und das ist ja eigentlich
dann an sich nicht so schlecht sein kann
das ist ja auch interessant also ich
würde auch damit nicht sagen also um
Gottes Willen keine
technologieverteufelung man kann sagen
Technologie ist nicht gut nicht böse
nicht neutral aber sie wirkt
verschärfend und das ist der Punkt
eine Sekunde
mit einem anderen Vorschlag in die Runde
kommen Bildung ist natürlich ein Faktor
Medienbildung aber
wir im also wir als Ampel haben im
Koalitionsvertrag den Vorschlag der
Plattform rette noch definiert das sind
da geht's dann quasi um den Bereich der
gar nicht justiziabel ist aber immer
noch ein problematisch und der findet
also dieser Rat könnte einfach ein
relevanter Faktor sein zur Verbesserung
der Situation könnte vorschreiben oder
vielleicht
Interpretationshilfen leisten in dem
Bereich könnte
Angebote liefern was die Algorithmen
angeht die müssen sowieso transparenter
gestaltet werden und also diese Geräte
würden funktionieren ähnlich für
Rundfunkgeräte und wären dann quasi auch
in einem Äquivalent also
wenn das nationales Gesetz ist dann ist
das nationales Gesetz also ehrlich
gesagt gab es auch schon Diskussion ob
man das dann digitale Dienste gesetzt
auf europäischer Ebene anwendet das hat
man nicht gemacht aber auf nationaler
Ebene kann man das immer noch machen und
dann ist das natürlich auch eine
Grundlage an der man sich orientieren
müsste sondern kommt auf die
Zusammenstellung an am besten
Wissenschaft betroffenen Organisationen
Menschen die sich auskennen mit der
Technik im Hintergrund und dann legt man
da einfach auch in irgendeiner Form
Regeln fest
die wollten noch was sagen
Antworten zu dem Aspekt der Bildung
Bildung ist großartig allerdings
erreicht Schulbildung natürlich nur
einen sehr sehr kleinen Teil der
Menschen viele sind aus der Schule schon
einfach durch und wir müssen aufpassen
dass wir mit einem Vorschlag nehmen wir
sozusagen alternativ in die Runde werfen
nicht die anderen beiseite wischen weil
auch die Idee mit den Räten und das
Recht ist natürlich nur ultimer Art so
völlig richtig aber müssen dran gehen
alle diese Hebel zu ziehen weil kein
einzelner Hebel das Problem alleine
lösen kann und insofern dürfen wir da
einfach nicht locker lassen und uns
nicht davon einlullen lassen das eine
kleine Lösung die aber schwer zu
erreichen ist das problemlos und alleine
wirken sollen ich würde noch mal gerne
auf wir haben jetzt viel über Elon Musk
gesprochen aber wir haben ja auch
saker work wir haben Jeff Bezos also das
sind ja drei sehr mächtige Männer wenn
man so haben die zu viel Macht der Boxen
ich würde sagen ja
ganz merkwürdiges paradox der digitalen
Zeit auf der einen Seite eine
gigantische Öffnung des kommunikativen
Raumes jeder kann sich zuschalten und
das ist erstmal eine wunderbare
Nachricht weil auch viele Menschen auch
das gehört zu einem gerechten Bild eine
Stimme bekommen die vorher keine harten
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir eine
totale macht vermacht und das
kommunikativen Raum ist ganz wenige ja
die wie Feudalherren in der alten Zeit
agieren ich nenne ihn mal eine einzelne
Zahl in diesem Jahr werden drei
Unternehmen mehr als die Hälfte aller
Werbeeinnahmen weltweit für sich
vereidigen können auf sich zu lassen
52%, das ist Google das ist Meta bzw
Facebook und das ist Amazon gleichzeitig
erleben wir und das ist Demokratie
politisch ein gravierender Verlust
wieder Lokal und Tageszeitung
Journalismus in diesem Land und in
vielen anderen Ländern der westlichen
Welt stranguliert wird weil ihm die
Werbeerlöse weg schwimmen und weil er
kein ausreichendes Geschäftsmodell hat
und diese vermachtung von Öffentlichkeit
die muss einen beunruhigen und die
nebenbei bemerkt die beunruhigt auch
manche der der
plattformunternehmer selbst ja die sind
ja die die gucken ja sehr interessiert
nach Europa das kann ich nach diesen
Reisen durch Silicon Valley wirklich
sagen ich komme sehr nach interessiert
nachdem was machen die mit dem
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz da was
machen die mit dem Service die warten
eigentlich auf die Regulierung um die
Zerschlagung zu vermeiden durchaus auch
strategischen Gesichtspunkten
gesagt das ist Punkte gibt bei allem was
die das ja als Visionär gearbeitet hat
bei den anderen bei Jeff Base ist bei
Max dackelberg das Menschen wo man sagt
die haben einfach was umgesetzt solche
Figuren gibt es eben in Europa in
Deutschland
also die haben auf jeden Fall so viel
umgesetzt dass wir hier heute sitzen uns
uns und uns über die unterhalten und und
wie wir angefangen haben ja auch die
Diskussionsrunde zu Beginn
Milliarden von Menschen sind sozusagen
auf diesen sozialen Netzwerken und
kommunizieren miteinander oder bestellen
bei Amazon oder was auch immer also das
hat die haben selbstverständlich unsere
Gegenwart zutiefst geprägt und ganz viel
geschaffen und ich finde das auch in
Ordnung dass auch herauszustellen und zu
sagen da ist unglaublich viel
enormes kreiert worden was uns zu dem
Punkt gebracht hat wo wir heute sind und
das bringt aber eben auch
Schwierigkeiten und auch demokratische
Schwierigkeiten und gesellschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten mit sich was mir noch
mal wichtig wäre auch zu sagen wenn wir
die ganze Zeit über Regulierung und so
weiter sprechen selbst Personen die sich
dann im Unternehmen in dem Unternehmen
das Netzwerks befinden und dann dort
gucken sollen was muss denn jetzt
gelöscht werden und was nicht das sind
doch auch nur Menschen die haben
politische Position die haben eine
Einstellung die haben die haben Ängste
die haben die haben Sorgen wie kommen
wir denn auf die Idee den dann die Macht
dafür zu geben zu regulieren was richtig
und was falsch ist Kriterien genau
deswegen müssen wir kontrolliert werden
sie müssen dann noch mal kontrolliert
werden genau und wenn wir sehr und dann
und nur noch mal nur und man macht dann
Gesetze und dann und das funktioniert ja
wunderbar wenn wir in einer liebevollen
Demokratie leben aber wir haben ja auch
eine AFD z.B was ist wenn die plötzlich
eine Bundestagswahl gewinnt und und ein
Land führt und mit Gesetzen agiert mit
Gesetzen agiert die z.B existieren also
wir reden über über Idealsituation wo
dann gesellschaftlich alles noch in
Ordnung ist aber was ist wenn wir
sozusagen politisch an einem Punkt
kommen der zum
unsere Demokratie und keine Gesetze mehr
keine keine Kriterien ich sage nicht was
die Folge ich will nur sagen dass wir
darüber nachdenken müssen dass wir aus
Idealsituation heraus kommunizieren und
wir gehen von von Menschen die Frage ist
für mich immer was ist das für ein
Menschenbild zu glauben da da können
könnte man Leute positionieren die sagen
dann äh das muss gelöscht werden das
unter die haben dann rechts und die
anderen
machen können
auch in der Diskussion sollte man
Facebook so viel Macht geben zu
entscheiden was gelöscht wird oder nicht
aber wir haben keine Alternative dazu
wir können nicht alles zu Gericht
schicken sondern wir sagen den das in
die Regeln und danach werden diese
Entscheidungen begründet und überprüft
das ist übrigens genau diese Regel die
Twitter nicht umsetzen wollte das
gegenvorstellungsverfahren wir brauchen
genau solche Instrumente damit diese
Menschen auch wiederum die kontrolliert
werden bzw die Maßnahmen danach z.B von
einem Gericht überprüft werden können
das ist nicht ideal aber es ist das
Beste was wir haben also vielleicht da
noch eine Ergänzung diese Plattform Rede
die Sie ins Spiel gebracht haben und dir
tatsächlich auch im Koalitionsvertrag
benannt sind sind auch deshalb so
interessant weil sie genau eine Instanz
und Institution sein könnten und
Transparenz Pflichten zu erzwingen sie
haben recht niemand soll auf irgendeiner
hinter der Bank Entscheidung treffen für
Milliarden für Menschen sondern aber
einschätzungsfähig zu werden als Userin
oder User gefällt mir eigentlich die
Politik meiner Plattform da könnten
solche Transparenzpflichten und solche
plattformräte durchaus hilfreich
mit dieser Runde dazu beigetragen etwas
mehr Transparenz zu schaffen vielen Dank
Frau Funke perksen Juden und Frau Kahn
für die Diskussion ihnen vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen sind schon wieder am Ende
aber wir bleiben auch noch ein bisschen
bei Twitter können Sie uns folgen bei
Phoenix und auch ganz normal im
Fernsehen sehen und jetzt folgt Phoenix
der Tag bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]